hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Samantha
Ashley bells today we're gonna check out
a video from all-time tense 10 shocking
facts about Disney I'm interested to
hear what they gotta say I hope they
cover that whole like it's ain't sex and
The Lion King and the mermaid Castle
looking like a penis whatever
of course you'd know these
Pinocchio's premier lemon niches for
hire to dress like puppets and wait
they got drunk and naked students
decane copycat of Disneyland lice 20
miles 32 kilometers outside of Beijing
Wow
120 acre amusement parking was abandoned
in 2000 every way every Christmas Walt
Disney would give his housekeepers
talking kissing away how rich is she
when she died Shannon 192,000 sucks
amassing a 9.5 million fortune [ __ ]
California New Zealand there is a club
33 up a private or restaurant that has
only five apologies for that midnight
joining fee is $25,000 blessing $10,000
a year memory this is true in Lincoln 3
early 1951 comic book strip shows making
a new be taking pepper which hardly
resembles amphetamines die boom eight
cents that makes sense
Disney force the daycare senator remove
an unauthorized Minnie Mouse
they also prevented a carving and
winning the throne a child's gravestone
oh [ __ ] if you spend one night in every
single room available all the Disney
World resorts it would take 68 years to
sleep in all of them 605 Japanese
cartoon Kimba the White Lion is almost
identical to the winding is these states
as coincidental but entire scenes and
characters are the same [ __ ] rip them
off man this in nature documentary
popular is the mythic lemmings commit
mass suicide the scene was staged the
lemmings are not flips the film won an
Oscar
Wow
I would act design the pink of Epcot
Center for it
the color critiques of red receptors and
Isis and grass actually looks green
interesting okay my favorite fact has
got to be number 10 the fact that
midgets were dressed up and then went
crazy because I got drunk has got to be
one of the coolest things anyone has
ever witness at that time I would love
to this day to see midgets go at it that
would be so [ __ ] fun and the fact
that there's you know a fair bit of them
yelling obscenities around children that
kind of says hilarious
you know midgets are an interesting
subject because you know it's like
they're people they're human beings but
sometimes it's did a little difficult
not to stare yeah I mean you just not
used to seeing them yeah I feel like I
need more [ __ ] friends I don't have
any [ __ ] friends let's go find some
can we put on a Craigslist ad that would
be a hunt I would love it we're gonna
find some [ __ ] friends let's record
this - I feel like they would need to
follow along on this adventure a [ __ ]
with big tits is what we need imagine a
[ __ ] with a huge dick I'm sure that
exists a black [ __ ] number nine I find
super interesting because I know that
there is isn't there a Disneyland and is
it Beijing or where is it there's an
over you honestly think I would know the
geographical destination of where this
Disneyland Park is another country never
mind never mind do you not know who I am
I forgot I got penises and vaginas and
the occasional butthole anyway I want to
look this up because I'm curious if this
is actually true if there is a copycat
of Disneyland
that's decaying I feel like that'd be
really sad but then footage of it but
you can meet they could put fake footage
of it I don't know are you accusing all
time tens of being a liar I'm not
accusing them of being a liar I'm just
gonna fact-check by what going on Google
is that you're fat check I'm winning I'm
gonna die got it go I'm going to gene
I'm going to beat I'm going to go to
Beijing I don't know man they don't like
girls well Walt Disney gave his uh what
was their maid yeah a stock and she had
like nine million dollars in stock that
is
nuts I I would have if if Walt Disney
told me I'll give you nine million
dollars in stocks like I'll be your mate
for life
I've yeah I would have you know made him
a little Mickey Mouse down there you
know made him a little too happy lick
him a little bit calls him behave little
goofy huh Oh Donald suck you know to me
oh okay yeah um doom in the Winnie the
Pooh hole you know to me you're ruining
my childhood man I mean Walt Disney for
you so there's this place that they
mentioned club 33 which I have been to
it's so cool so the orgy Club know it's
an orgy club
I don't know 33 is that an orgy number
what would that mean every number is an
orgy number as long as there's more than
three people in both either way so I
don't were G close three or more I'm
sorry there is this door that's right
next to the exit of Pirates of the
Caribbean and you'll just see this like
little sign that says 33 and it's kind
of shiny um and then it's just this gray
door and they actually like
scientifically found the color that is
least um like I guess prominent to the
human eye that you you uh I guess would
pass over the most so they try to make
it like the dullest color they could
that is least noticeable scientifically
proven um and that's the color of the
door and when you say scientifically
proven were these uh science facts
coming from I don't know science
someone said scientifically proven you
just took their word for it well don't
be a dick hey hey hey they're saying
that The Lion King
looks like they said it was complete
coincidence that it came across like
Kimba the White Lion from Japan
no we completely with them it's called
Kimba sounds just like Mufasa and Nala
idiots Simba who's Simba
he really doesn't know much about Disney
ah that's not true I saw Shrek that was
a great movie uh him and the lego movie
[ __ ] hilarious and Ted no dude that's
DreamWorks anyway guys thanks for tuning
in to the channel if you're new to it
you can subscribe to the real rejects
you can check out
Samantha Ashley fields channel you can
boss on Facebook Instagram Twitter vine
and periscope I want to give a shout out
to Samantha's sister Amanda Amanda I
hope your life is going well Amanda I
can't give too many details about her
I'm not gonna reveal her real last name
but I will say this Amanda um she talked
she opened my eyes to the possibility of
one day going to a strip club you know I
thought like wow this woman really likes
strip clubs and it just seems to be such
a part of her nature her personality
that I was like okay okay maybe I'll go
one day then I saw Magic Mike double-xl
and I realized I want to be a stripper
one day this is for you Amanda boom boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
Amanda